输出是一个非常幸福的事情，就是你比如说你看了什么书，你有什么感悟，你看了什么电视，你有什么感悟，你看了什么电影，你有什么想法，你今天经历了什么事儿，你看了什么网上什么事儿，你有什么感悟。输出是一件很幸福的事情，通过持续的输出去学习这件事情是特别值得所有人都干的事情，因为我们输出的过程当中，未必是说一定让自己成名成家，未必让自己能够有很多粉丝能挣到钱。因为你输出的过程当中，其实是在寻找同类，寻找同频的人，寻找志同道合的人，是这么个过程。冷菲姐，你好，我是昨天连过的，也就是说，拿了分手证之后，这个男方求和无诚意嘛，不愿意对现在的每个月2000了吧，我记得分手4个月了，孩子1岁，你自己呢，是有一份稳定的工作。然后你是本科生，是我了。因为我其实很多东西，我是有自己判断，但是关键就是我容易受他人话语的影响。因为很多人都强调说，不要为还没有发生的事情焦虑担忧嘛，我就怕我是主观上放大了我想那些困难，然后导致我做出错误的决定，然后我又没有靠谱的人商量，所以我还是有一些具体的问题，我就今天又过来连线，想听听您的建议。第一件事情就是我昨天不是说。
不回去是因为他们家不愿意兑现那个承诺嘛。那如果后期他们又愿意兑现那个每个月2000的承诺，那您觉得就根据他们家的这个情况，就是父母没有退休金养老金，只靠爸爸一个人挣钱，大概还能挣两到三年吧。家里还有那个遗传性糖尿病，目前就是老公就是没稳定收入，婆婆强势，三个姐姐可能还需要娘家的帮衬，就这种情况，你觉得如果他愿意给我一些每个月资金的帮助，我要回去吗？我说心里话啊，就是你的这个状态，你回到那个家庭了之后，你的所有的人际关系也是都在消耗你的生命力的，都在消耗你的元神的是吧？因为婆婆跟你关系也不是很好，老公这头又不怎么维护你，而且，老公又没什么本事，老公也没有稳定的工作，光靠公公说还能干两年。干两年之后，公公就退休了。婆婆公公又没有任何的退休保障。到时候婆婆公公一病了，什么事儿都得靠你。只有你一个人有稳定的收入，只有你一个人能够稳定的给家里面挣钱。到时候就算他现在兑现了一个月给2000块钱，等公公两年之后挣不着钱了，人家也就不兑现这个事儿了。我感觉这就是无底洞，因为几个姐姐三个姐姐都过得不好，都是离了婚，带着孩子的经济条件都很差，没有一个人能帮衬上全家人。到时候都得拖你的后腿，公公婆婆也得拖你的后腿，你。
公也得拖你的后腿，就因为昨天我妈她还跟我说要他们愿意的话，她也觉得小孩太小，让我回去。但是我就说这些担忧朋友说那都是他家的事，不让我管。姐妹啊，我再给你支个招。如果你实在是心疼孩子，实在是舍不得孩子，假设有一天他们妥协了，说一个月给贴补2000块钱，你就算回去过的话，你也别领结婚证，这个我知道，那我就放心了。因为现在他们可能还会问我回不回，然后我就害怕，我直接表明就是不愿意回去，怕他们就不愿意让我看小孩。我觉得就这个方面，他们再问我回不回，我应该怎么去表达呢？就看情况呗。我现在这个身体不太好，心里也有抑郁症，我先把我的抑郁症治疗一下，对孩子也好点，这么推脱呗，就不用说再去换别的这个要求条件让他们去满足了，不用行。因为我针对于这个分手证之后，嘛，以我的认知和经历，我觉得就是一个名存实亡，有怨气的这个婚姻给小孩带来伤害，他并不亚于就是大人分开之后给给小孩带来伤害嘛。所以当时分开我就跟他说，如果真的爱孩子的话，我们就是和平分开，不要在孩子面前说对方的坏话。嘛，把大人的矛盾强加在孩子身上，我是能做到的。我在家确实也是这样做的，但是他就是给我来一句，因为他家女人多嘛，女人多，然后孩子也多。
他就说他管不了，做不到，所以现在都建议把孩子先放男方家养。但是，我就害怕他们肯定要说我坏话，孩子之后跟我不亲，这个问题咋整？实话说，这事儿呢，也跟孩子自带的慧根有关系。如果孩子他自带慧根，他懂得识别善恶，他懂得识别好歹的话，其实他慢慢长大了之后，他会从不同的角度来看待这个问题，但有的孩子他就认死理儿，呃这两天不是看那个生万物那个电视剧嘛，他有的孩子他就是有慧根的。他慢慢长大了之后，他就能分辨是非对错，能分辨谁不容易，能分辨谁是好人，谁真心对我好。有的孩子他真的我说这话就是让你放宽心，如果有一天你的孩子他是那种他就不识好歹的，你也得放手，也得放手，真的是这样，我知道那所以说就是为了未来做准备吧，就是关于这个抚养权这个问题，我看昨天评论有人说什么两岁以下更好，要到8岁孩子自己选。我想请您根据我这个情况给我提一些思路，这样机会来的话，我到时候心里就有数。就是在孩子成长的这个过程当中，我们肯定在我们时间精力允许的范围之内，尽量多陪伴他。每次去陪伴他的时候，我们一定要留下痕迹，一定要拍照啊，拍视频啊，给孩子买个什么东西。
东西啊，也得要留下痕迹，有购物的记录呀，今天给孩子买了新衣服，我跟孩子要拍个照啊，这些所有的东西都要留下来。其实有的时候我们一辈子活就活这么几个片段，就活这么几个闪现。真到时候我自己很强大了，我心里也强大，然后能量也足够，我挣钱也稳定，我以后的日子也过得很顺当的时候，我想争孩子抚养权，我就大大方方的争孩子的抚养权。然后，8岁了之后，孩子有自己选择的权利，就是不要担心两岁之后，可能就是不好争取什么。因为你现在的现实情况确实不允许你带孩子了。妈妈又帮衬不上啊，妈妈得了这个病又帮衬不上你，你自己又要上班儿。你的这个班儿呢，又是属于那种体制内的，你也不可能天天请假啊，是吧？你确实现在条件不成熟。然后就是昨天您给我的这个最大建议就是让我抓紧挣钱嘛，我也想我有两个思路，因为我目前是在小县城的体制内开车10分钟内我就能到家。如果想提高这个工资的话，我是要不往市里或者是更好的地方再考，那么这样的一个好处就是它有利于我换个环境，避免那些闲言碎语的压力，也好让我重新开始生活。这是一个我想的思路。然后另外一个就是你目前工作不变，这样的好处就是方便我看孩子，然后在小县城自己买房，压力会小，我不知道。
我现在应该是把力量用在哪一条方向上，如果你考进去了之后，你要回来看孩子的话，要多长时间呢？那也不远，那就考尽量考一考是吧？对，换个环境，换个活法。如果做兼职的话，因为像这种工作的话，做兼职就像您昨天跟我说的那个什么，3年为一辈子，3年让自己焕然一新，我觉得这个也是一个思路，或许我可以做一个账号来记录这3年自己的成长，你觉得这样也行吗？可以输出是一个非常幸福的事情，就是你比如说你看了什么书，你有什么感悟，你看了什么电视，你有什么感悟，你看了什么电影，你有什么想法，你今天经历了什么事儿，你看了什么网上什么事，你有什么感悟，输出是一件很幸福的事情。通过持续的输出去学习这件事情是特别值得所有人都干的事情。因为我们输出的过程当中，未必是说一定让自己成名成家，未必让自己能够有很多粉丝能挣到钱。因为你输出的过程当中，其实是在寻找同类，寻找同频的人，寻找志同道合的人，是这么个过程，就是彼此支撑吧。因为我现在，我感觉自己是没有任何可以依靠的，就有一种没有归宿的感觉。最后一个就是因为我跟他的事情有两件事卡在我心里，我自己想不明白，我不知道是他在丢。
亏还是说真是我的错，就是我想让你帮我判断一下。有一件事情就是说他一直说，就是我这个结婚3年没有任何付出，唯一的付出就是生了孩子，然后还是给我做思想工作生的。但是我就指出来了嘛，我就说他这个结婚第一年做生意，我给他当担保人，然后他赔了我还帮他还了小几万的贷款。我认为这是我的付出，然后他直接否认掉了他的意思就是这是夫妻风险共同承担的，这是他赔了。如果他要赚的话，那他的钱还要给我花呢。我感觉他说的对，好像又不对，但是我怎么觉得听着这么不舒服呢？我又没办法反驳他。我跟你讲，就这事儿的话，如果一个男人他完全没有办法共情女人怀孕生孩子的这个苦难，生孩子的这个付出，大概率下他就是一个空心人。我们就是他没有家也没有出轨，但是我就是生活很痛苦的原因，那你离开是对的。我老跟大家讲一个最简单的一个逻辑，就是说有条狗怀孕了，家里的狗猫怀孕了，你是不是都想着得给它热点热饭啊，给它整点骨头汤，给它整点什么有营养的是吧？但凡是有一点点这个同理心，有一点点这个怜悯心悲悯心的人的话，就是个正常人。就算哪条狗和猫，你养的猫和狗怀孕了，你都会心疼他，不容易啊。但如果说一个男人对女人怀。
怀孕生孩子这个事儿，他觉得这算什么东西，这算什么事儿？平天下女人都得生，就你矫情，那你就离开就是对的。第二件事就是他们想让我回去，但是不愿意整个兑现2000。然后我一提这个孩子非常的生气，他的观念就是什么呢？他家认为孩子爸不挣钱，但是孩子妈有工资，家里有困难，为什么不能用自己的工资去养孩子？就这一点冲突很大，因为我心里很憋屈嘛。我想的是，催生的时候，我知道经济问题是我最大的担忧，但是他家自己主动提出来，就是每个月给资助，我才考虑，我才敢生的。现在我生完了，给我来一句这人说的话就不能因时事而变了。我就是现在，我有一种我被骗子生孩子的感觉，就是欺负我孩子塞不回去。本来就是啊，客观的就是你被骗了呀，我只是没好意思这么说，就是你被骗了呀。对呀，我就是阐述了我的憋屈和不满，他们就说说我自私，说我孩子自己生了就该自己养，我都发现我都感觉跟吵不过他们一样。我有一种感觉啊，我感觉就是你老公和你婆婆他们这样的人就是我穷，我有理。我给你讲一个逻辑，你就明白了。就是我先说我自己有套房，先说我自己的工作是当医生的。我把你骗过来了之后，让你生完孩子了之后，我再告诉你这个房子是租的。
我只是在医院当一个保安，然后当你生气的时候，我还说我如果不骗你，你怎么可能跟我结婚呢？我如果不骗你，你怎么可能跟我生孩子呢？那我必须骗你，我才能有这个孩子呀。我有什么错呢？你理解这个逻辑了吗？跟你老婆婆和你老公是一样的逻辑。对，就是我其实刚生完孩子那会儿，我知道家里这个困难，她失业又要盖他家房子，当时没有说硬去要当时的这个承诺，是因为我现在我跟他生活很痛苦，那么他现在想让我回去过，我总觉得那你需要改变一下现实情况，对不对？所以我觉得我又没有这个提高要求，我只是让他兑现之前的承诺，我觉得不过分。但是为什么他们就是说怨恨我姐妹啊，这太正常了，为什么他们会怨恨你？有些人是说我从你身上借不到钱，我就怨恨你，我从你身上占不到便宜，我就怨恨你，我从你身上骗不到利益了，我就怨恨你。你不要在自己身上去找原因，你身上最大的原因就是当初瞎，或者说你当初没有跟着龙飞姐学一下怎么识人变人，这是你最主要的问题。你本就不该找这样的家庭，你想你自己是有体制内的正式的工作的。你是本科生，完了之后，你找一个什么样的家庭呢？公公婆婆是将来是没有退休金、没有社保的，没有医保的男的是没有正经工作的，完了之后，男的还有3个姐姐，3个姐姐都是离了婚带着孩子。
孩子的都是属于那种需要娘家支撑的，你本就不该找这样的家庭，这是你的错。反正就是这两件事卡在我心里，所以在大家看来，这不是我的观念的问题。因为他还说我三观不合，他也说我会把孩子教坏啊。你幸运的是什么？幸运的是你现在全须全眼儿，你现在身体还是健康的，你已经拿到了那个分手证了，这是你的幸运，你要是掉进那种NPD的窝子里面的那个家，你掉进这样的环境里的话，你没我就是你幸运，你没有抑郁，自就是你幸运。就是现在不管怎么样，都建议我不要再回去跟他是的，没错。那现在的局势就是反正人家心里还等着我今晚回去呢，然后我现在是还在他们家微信群里，就这个事情也挺尴尬的，退群就多了嘛，这没啥。我有的时候人家会往群里发孩子视频，我就有一点贪恋这一点，我就想着如果他们踢我，那就踢我，他们不踢我，我就先就这样待着吧。反正我也不说话，也不露脸了，可以啊。然后这是个微信群的事情，那我下次我见他们去家里接孩子，我是以什么态度呢？是该叫啥叫啥呢，因为我又害怕闹得太难堪。演戏嘛，如果说为了让自己见孩子方便，咱就演戏嘛。叫声爹叫声妈，也不会少一块肉。这么跟你说，能够让我顺利的见孩子，亲亲孩子，抱抱孩子，你别说让我叫爹叫。
妈妈，你让我跪都可以行，那我之后我就打算跟他们协商。我就周末的时候带孩子回回娘家，过两天好，就这样啊，拜拜，都去给我点关注。